hello
these are hiding welcome to our
presentation by me together with my
colleagues ke mo Empoli like a regarding
our reading progress in dissecting the
mechanism underlying emotional learning
associated with our instructure quarter
amygdala
our learning experience is often heavily
associated with our emotions such as the
fear and reward this well exemplified by
the saying that once bitten twice shy
and you can better this guy after an
electric shock fear will make him had a
hard hump of the hand on another similar
origin and this is a good in many ways
they help us to navigate away from
potential dangers but it's in common too
much of it can also be problematic
firmly in the case of opposed to make a
stress stress disorder the extremely
extreme emotional retardation emotional
charge the war theme all over me and
many soldiers had a hard hum to come
back to their normal daily life at a
later time
so this fear learning whether it's good
or bad it's a largely mediated by an an
almond-shaped structure called the
amygdala as deep in the brain and if we
lose the function of the emitter such as
in this patient SM she had lesions in
both Society of her amygdala and even
under the most fearful conditions will
most people tremble should feel
comfortable and laugh an additional
research has established that the middle
function is associated with depression
aggression anxiety fear PTSD bipolar
disorders a hole right here
of a neuro psychiatric disease
I in addition to to fear the amygdala is
also important for other type of
emotions such as seeking a reward and
you can better in terms of reverse
seeking in the extreme case it's
addiction so the myth is also associate
with addictions what I have helped you
suffice that the McCullough is important
for a large number of new psychiatric
disease ala and also is important for
normal functions
I will knowing that the Miller is
important it's one thing knowing how it
works is different and we really need to
know how the emitter work in order to be
able to provide treatments to some other
psychiatric diseases it's very similar
to the case they're like in a computer
most people know that the CPU is a super
important for the computer's function
but at the same time knowing how the CPU
work is a different story and that's
where our research team are try to do
for the emitter society the function of
amygdala we use a mouse as our model
system the function of emitter is a
highly controlled between mouse and
human in including the structure as well
and and advantage of using Mouse of
course is that this give us a large
number of experimental animals allowed
it's much easier to amenable to
experimental designs and so allow us to
care for control experiments and there
has also been a large body of literature
already studying how the amygdala
functions in Mouse is allow us to stand
on the shoulders of giants and in prayer
for our research team we try to
understand that a mr. Howie function at
a low level of neuronal circuits as
illustrated by this schematic here the
emitter is a represent by a group of
blue neurons that are at the middle
layer and this in fact is a very under
represent of the amygdala and has
hundreds of thousands of neurons and
each neuron filter has received inputs
from upstream brain regions and they
also send their projection to the
downstream
origins and from all this output centers
they program like handling to influence
a different animal behaviors such as
animal defense versus reward seeking if
without any prior knowledge then one
have to assume that any of the input
brain region has some probability to
connect for every one of this neuron but
from the amygdala neurons to the output
centers so this can give us a very
complex diagram which is not exactly
easy to study by the same time if you
think about probably not order order
polynomial regions that can send a
projection would connect to the amygdala
and and also for emitter does not output
to every single of centers so if one can
pin such information the diagram become
log simplified and in a vision based on
our chronology of amygdala and also how
the brain is organized in other part of
the brain the emitter is likely consists
of who many functional sub regions and
then also in each function of sub region
like that the neurons come in different
subtypes as to represent either
different colors here and what a common
theme like in neuronal circuit is there
like a one particular input in region
does not connect to all the functional
domains in fact it may connect only to
one or a few of the functional domain
and then in some other input regions may
only connect one or a few subtype of the
neurons so and similar things can also
be safe from amygdala to its output
centers if one can pin such information
the wiring diagram can really greatly be
simplified is still fairly complex but a
lot more manageable compared to when we
start so for project like that the our
first goal is to understand the anatomy
and using this to understand with the
input and output wiring diagram of the
amygdala and this allow us to
the possibilities and easily easier
understand exactly what the amygdala is
doing then at the second level we want
to know like how the amygdala works kind
of voting on the animal behavior
the amygdala neurons has like a they
will fire the electrical activity is
called action potentials and seeing like
a which neurons are firing action
potential and how long how strong this
will give us crucial information in a
sec now how a material is computations
and in addition so I can know anatomy
and also sing this electro activity is
not enough so amygdala is the emotional
center so it received a lot of info
emotional informations and and this is
integrated into the computation I am
power so sorry select this integral into
the information and and the emotional
the emotional usually come in a variety
on a white away of the neuronal
communication core neuromodulation new
modulation unlike the typical electric
connections they are mediated by new
modulator instead such as the dopamine
in the case of reward or not in Efrain
in the case of stress like they are they
communicate in a way that is volumetric
in there like that they keep the tension
globally increase in the amygdala and
they can simultaneously interact with
thousands of neurons and depending on
what type of a neuron like a is there
and what have a receptor they are like
at the same new modulator can greatly
enhance the function of certain pathways
and at the same time can concretely
decrease the function of other pathways
this is more analogous to the
analogous to the DJ control halos like
in a music concert hold that control the
very complex electric circuits there so
you know to understand emitter function
we also need to be able to look at new
modulations so these are all these are
all demanding these are all demanding
like a tasks error and require a lot of
all expertise so therefore like all for
our project we bring in three different
labs like and here like I am more of a
technologist here there that we are
developing microscopy technique allow
one to senior modulations and my
colleague Cheney Mouse level she is a
modern qualitative anatomies allow her
to so so then she will look examine the
newer connectivities like her and that
allow us to consume the possibilities
and eventually bully our biologists here
will our biology here will basically
integrate the tools that we develop and
also the information enemy information
and try to eventually dissect out
exactly what's going on in the emitter
so for the remaining part of the
presentation it was separate into three
parts with each pop resembled a research
trip for their own progress and for the
first part I will show you some of our
reason advances in terms of
understanding neuromodulation astray the
simulation in different structures the
powerful ongoing long-term collaboration
with change lab and the picture here
laid by and way home our three retail
research associate who carry out most of
the experiments with help from our
collaborator Pole and also other
collaborators such as gene being at
Stanford and we're very grateful for NIH
and the pre initial funding so seeing no
modulation
is not exactly
easy even the same new modulator
selected they can they can depend on the
cell type and depend on the receptor
type they can have very different
effects on the neuronal functions but
few years back what we noticed elekid at
least a different new modulation pathway
they all converge onto one subsolar
signaling pathway for the psyche MP
pique pathway and dependent motility the
Newman part we may either actually or
inhibit this pathway and we really if we
can monitor the activity of this psyche
MP and pick a pathway we actually use it
as one way of readout who examine work
type of all new modulation events that
are happening in individual neurons so
this pathway by self is not easily
visible so we have to put in a probe in
our case a genetically encoded a sensor
or a kinase activity reporter into the
cells generally include sensor mean
selector it can be assembled together as
a piece of DNA and then we can have a
variety of ways to put this DNA into the
cell and then the cell use its own
transcription and translation machinery
can made a DNA into a protein and in
this protein it has a multiple
functional domains but on a tattoo end
there is a green fluorescent protein GFP
and also a red for example in IP when
the activity or signal pathway is low
the sensor atop a loose configuration
and the distance between G and RP are
long and there's a very little
interaction between JP and IP so if you
excited to be fluorescence you mostly
get a normal JP fluorescence and when
the activity of the pathway increased
but on the PK which is also called as a
complete dependent kinase can transfer a
phosphate group to the sensor T's for
the sensor in a closed configuration and
now the distance between to a PRP is
closed and there is at least a
phenomenal call for cell resonance
energy transfer of rare happen Wilfred
does is that it would chance for power
of the GP energy when GP is excited to
the RP what it
effectively does it decrease the GP for
instance and increase the corresponding
IP for essence and if one camera frame
one can measure the sensor activity of
the signaling pathway the sensor has
been developed for over 15 years and it
has been successfully applied in mutual
experiments such as the cell culture
however we want to do we want to is we
apply to the sensor in vivo which is a
much more challenging and pure has not
been successful over the past 15 years
and even if you like a with a lot of
trying arrow like we use a three pronged
approach like her i pair allow us to
achieve our code and the first one is
Teleca we use a different my cos we then
most people - we use a technique called
float on 4s and lifetime imaging
microscopy or - Keithley
most people would measure producing a
technical ratiometric imaging in which
people measure the GFP fluorescence and
aquifer engine and to a ratio of the two
the two a lifetime imaging has a lot but
when here compared to the more
conventional preferentially imaging in
that it's much more qualitative stable
and it's an iterative incentive to
change in the environments which is in
error inevitable in the in vivo imaging
conditions I am NOT going into the
Magnum or for the lifetime imaging but
if the the audience I want to know more
please check out this link here and in
another aspect but many different labs
has develop whole many variants of the
echo sensor and what we did is we shop
around and we compare all these
different sensors as I'm going to show
you like her in the next slide not all
of these sensors are the same and and
our shop around allow us to identify the
best sensor and from there we further
improve the path sense he will show you
some of the examples in this first
example we compare our microscopy the
lifetime imaging with the more
conventional ratiometric image
and so the Romanian is showing right
here as you can see once we go into a
print issue its value continue to change
and this may very hard to compare one
cell from another and one day from
another there's much harder to interpret
the results at the same time lifetime
imaging measurements showing blue here
is stable at different brain tissue tabs
and when we shop around it shows our
result of shopping around one the sensor
the purple one
really outperforms all the other sensors
and this is very important so that this
allow tells us that which sensor to use
and from there like a leaf further
improve the sensor shoe in green we have
a now have a sensor code here in
Karratha
it's very for respond to endogenous new
modulations actions not generally it's
an activity it's a response becomes
almost three times as big as the origin
of proper sensors so with these
improvements like this allow us to take
the sensor amiibos succesfully and we
can now routinely like a look at a
picking activity and use it as a readout
for new modulation tempo in the mouse
cortex and it in this example in the
mouse context that has been published we
can open the window in the mouse skull
is allow us to look at the neurons in
the mouse context and we can maybe pick
an activity there and in this example we
look at the effect of several
prescription drugs that is a prescribed
to human and they are known to affect
pighead pathways and sure enough that
these drugs they all
alter the PK activity in mouse cultural
neurons or they either increases
activity or decrease activity that is
considered with the maximum how they
would simply activity in the context is
one thing but but the amygdala is a tip
in the brain so like a nerd who CP
activity deep in the brain like that has
additional challenges and we need to
somehow be able to see the signal deep
imprint and in order to do this we use
we use of green lens which are very
similar to a needle still shows a
real-life example of a freelancer
compared to a penny as you can see the
Quinlan sir is a very likely Neto this
allow us to pull get ready with deep
into the mouse brain
I will read here some more damage and
you know experiments after we implement
the green lens the mouse's feel heavy
leave afterwards and it can sucessful
perform all the behavior tasks we asked
the mouse
in same time this needle is also a lens
this allows us to King optical SS deep
into the brain and in a testing case we
apply this technology to another deep
brain structure called a stratum which
is important for animal locomotion and
although si is function we let the mouse
either rest or run on a treadmill we can
measure SP we can also control the speed
of the treadmill if necessary and in
this last data slide we have the mouse
run for the mouse to rung and you can
see see them whenever the mouse run is a
big spy of opk activity and this really
the first time people have the ability
to read out these kind of activities and
and we are very excited about this
result and we are actually analyzing
this real
and looking for in the context of our
current project we are also very excited
of Teleca we will pay the deep brain
peak activity imaging as a reader for
new modulation in collaboration with
kenji and polly tried who are used to
read out the new modulation activity in
the context of emotional learning in the
amygdala thank you and with this lecture
I will turn over to my colleague Henry
for her part of the presentation
hi my name is Gianni Mao I'm associate
professor at the volume Institute at
Oregon Health and Science University the
data I'm gonna present to you today was
mainly carried out by Italian postdoc
Mike mania in my lab in close
collaboration with Yahoo among Sinai
with help from technician mountain chain
and my great collaborators Heinen's own
Empoleon esteem
my goal in this collaborative project is
to establish a comprehensive and
qualitative connectivity map for the
Machpelah and to identify the structural
features that make kind functional
studies at the cellular level as you
just heard from Heinen's presentation at
the behavioral level you are here from
Bali so we can make this analogy as the
reverse engineering of a computer chip
both of this are input/output apparatus
and both of this are connected
interconnected in very specific ways
that information can flow in very
defined directions and finally on the
neighboring parts are not necessarily
connected so we will have to be able to
track the wires and find all their
downstream target that might be far away
we want to figure out who is talking to
who in what manner and this needs to be
quantitatively and systematically in
order to do that our experimental
approach needs to satisfy at least the
following criteria but today's
presentation I will be focusing on
mapping the amygdala outputs first we
will have to use the tracers that allow
us to precisely label a middle and
neurons cell body locally and this
tracer have to be able to transport to
the neuronal process including the
neuronal axons that travel far away in
case of human this can be over a meter
we need to be able to image all the
potential targets of the medulla which
are known to spread widely and we need
high sensitivity so we can identify
single axons and thing and find axonal
processes because we have to apply those
tracers locally otherwise we'll be
losing at reasoning resolution we can
only put each tracer in one location per
break and we will need to sing increase
the significant number of animals to
cover the entire amygdala there
for we will need to develop methods that
allow us to compare crossed animals and
finally we will need to assemble the
quantitative input and output map and
that requires to develop computational
algorithms to meet all these criteria
our team harvest on the most recent
technology development in your science
engineering and computation first we
choose the tree sing methods I bio media
for essence expression fluorescence
proteins in this case we inject
adeno-associated virus AAV into a brain
region as you can see those price paths
from this fight and the fluorescence
protein is case green fluorescence
protein GFP will be expressed and filled
up the neuronal process you can trace
some of this process go across corpus
callosum and go to the other side of the
brain you can also see a few targets
that be labeled by going for essence
protein that's far away from the soma
now using these methods we inject a
similar virus into the medulla and shown
here as 2 pi spots and the bring is
viewed from the top with the nose
pointing to your left you can see that
indeed axonal of the amygdala
projections a white lace web also some
of projections goes to the midbrain and
this suggestion is confirmed the
necessity of using hopefully mapping
technology as I mentioned to the earlier
to ensure the tracer resolution we use
one trace tracer for brain so in order
to increase the data collection and data
and analysis efficiency here we're using
two different colors by injecting two
virus expressing green and red
fluorescence protein respectively GFP
and TD tomato in this case you can see
that with some small displacement the
green and red injections that into the
medulla have shared and distinct targets
this data will allow us to analyze
topographical relationship between
injections and their projection targets
as well as I mentioned increase the data
collection and data analysis efficiency
you probably can also notice some of the
process of those axons that he needs
indeed very thing in a fighh so to
ensure that we can detect those axons at
all targets of the medulla we use
antibody staining to amplify the signal
in this case we use antibody against gfp
proteins and TD tomato proteins
respectively my example is showing the
bottom left is the image that before
antibody staining and on the right is
after staining suggesting that the
antibody staining is necessary for us to
detect axons at the projection target
now with this high resolution high
sensitivity imaging we end up pretty
typical 1 terabytes of data per print so
data visualization and data analysis are
still challenging with data size as such
our next slide I will show you example
where we put together the original
images using the imaging sequence we
collect the data but here we displayed
it using vertical section to allow us to
look at the different reference between
the points so please play the video
going forward with civil this hundred
injections in hand as I mentioned
earlier we aim to construct a
comprehensive input-output map for the
medulla this is build upon our previous
tremendous experience constructing other
brain circuits in similar scale
hopefully will develop novel algorithms
that specific analyzing mcdowell s
property just give you a few example of
how we have done this previously for
example we can look at a relationship of
many injections as showing example here
as Y injection if we project to the
target we label this injection as a
positive injection if it's been
surrounded by many other injections that
do not project to one of our targets we
can actually construct the injection
origin by subtracting the negative
injections also another example is that
we were able to consider information
that comes from different sources and
project to the comprehensive target as
labeled here as information source and
to the information target this analysis
that allow us to understand in a
comprehensive way whether the potential
sub regions of the medulla projecting to
all their targets furthermore using our
methods we have previously shown that we
can use input and output to define the
Breen sub regions that are functionally
relevant for example at the top is the
sub regions of the brain structure
called psalmist which we constructed by
using their projection targets in the
middle is the stratum sub regions we
reconstructed using the input to the
screen region many of these sub domains
are now being shown by many other labs
in the field to be important for the
function and readout of these circuits
we're hoping that using this data set we
can do the same for medulla which is
allow us to have the comprehensive input
and output map and importantly
to label sub-regions amygdala that's a
functional irrelevant and we can pass
the information to beliefs lab to test
them in the behavior hi this is the body
I'm a professor in neuroscience in
cosmic Harbor life I'm going to be
focusing on the third part of this
collaborative project that is to
determine how cellular he wins with
indiscreet amygdala serve use contribute
to each area so first of all I would
like to thank the people who are working
on this project including people in my
lab at the cusp and our lab this include
three talented individuals a young Kylie
and read her sri Shama
i would also like to thank my
collaborators hangjun anak ng model that
we are reading health and science
university his work is supported by the
grant from a nice brain initiative so
here we're going to focus on two
different about behaviors one about
behavior is defensive area that is
driven by our system and a second type
of behavior is called the reward seeking
area which is driven by rewarding
stealing so we can to look at activities
of neurons in the amygdala in mice
performing these two very different kind
of behavior so in the amygdala within to
image the calcium activities of
individual neurons which is a proxy of
the firing of action potentials in these
neurons in addition we are also going to
image neuromodulation activity in this
new box this neuromodulatory activity
may represent the emotional aspects of
different stimuli including both the
worship stimuli as well as the rewarding
of stimuli so here is a diagram of the
amygdala so we're gonna focus on the
same
so part of the emitter called
essentially so this product the amygdala
has been shown by many studies in the
past including the study in our lab that
control both defensive behavior and also
we will see can be here so neurons in
the central mcdonough can be identified
based on a specific genetic marker that
the Express exam or one kind of neuron
shown in red here express a specific
genetic marker called because it out and
there is a different type of neuron
shown in blue here express different
kind of genetic marker called as a
matter study or so so the peak is a
patent Iran and a study neuron in the
central Mikula
are embedded in a different input output
circuit
Preble study indicate that is to cut off
neurons may play different roles in
defensive was the reward seeking
behavior but how exactly this Newroz
participate or confidence loops are to
be Ilias is still unclear so how are we
going to study the functional experience
so we're going to use mice as introduced
to you already by my collaborator honey
and germanic anymore because we have a
genetic tools to allow the target
specific neurons in the amygdala is the
knowledge about markers so for example
we can use wars using different promoter
to target either because mm iran or
estimate study in iran in the same for
Victor and this allows us to introduce
activity indicators into this neuron and
then we will imply the green lines on
top of this me wrong and through this
Greenland were able to image the
activity of the infection iran's young
either one photo or two-photon
microscopy so the animals will be
trained in specific behavioral tasks for
example we can train the animal to learn
to associate
some with a worship stimulus such as
hell shock and also train the same
animal to associate it with a different
sound - to associate a different sound
with a rewarding stimuli as a water
reward its animals are water deprive the
so be aware thirsty so water is what we
wanted so this behavior paradigm
together with the imaging method will
allow us to look at the response
properties of different hard nosed but
different stimuli including different
sounds the tail shock and also the water
reward for example we have image the
activity of opiates data neurons in the
center of Machpelah in response to tell
shock so in this case we use the word
words to deliver gm6 which is a calcium
indicator into the piquancy data
numerals in the sink or Victor and then
we deliver shock through the tail of the
animal so on the right side you can see
in the field of view there are many new
rounds that had been imaged you can see
in the bottom on the right side for in
widow knew wrong Xiu Yin responses to
the shocked with the shock delivery
littell so roughly about 50% of anyone
through strong responses to to the shop
so currently we also come across the
response properties of this neuron to
reward even a frequency of a song or to
a different punishment or worship
stimuli such as brilliant to the face so
in addition currently we are also using
two P two photon flip image to image PP
activity of these neurons essentially
the matter methodology is the same as
what hanim Jim already is probably in
the first part of this talk the only
difference is that here we're going to
image the PPA activity in the central
amygdala
instead of windows writer and in the
animal that to learn to use sound to
predict either the tail shock or a
reward the eventually we were hoping to
be able to image both Kika activity and
calcium activity in the same neuron in
the animal that perform either the award
similar name or the reward money
so besides a medium activities of the
neurons will also learn to determine the
rule of different habit when you are in
the same column vector the ability to
perform this big area so in this case we
need to be able to control the activity
of different neurons in the central
Mikula for example we can use a method
called optogenetics to inhibit the
neurons of the image in this case we
need to deliver a molecule that is
sensitive to light to the new ones of
the increase and then when we shine
lights onto this neuron we work
activities activities inhibitor and
therefore to selects at the neuron so
for example we haven't used this method
to hibbett but you can see that a new
wrong I do not fear conditioning
unless that allows us to observe that
this leads to the impairment of fear
memory formation so this colorful
manipulation allow us to establish a
causal relationship between a double
neuron and a specific type of period so
going forward our collaborative project
will allow us to determine how exactly
that because she doesn't new ones
contradict to fear learning including
fear conditioning in particular it will
allow us to for the first time to
describe how big are your activities in
this neuron is involving such kind of
learning in addition we want
most determine also at the rule of pkc
data activity it has it has a numeral
activity in every order and for the mall
to determine other kind of numerous
hotels a math study new role in
reordering and also a warranty so in
parallel as you already heard from my
collaborators I am a stock we will be
able to provide a detailed and a precise
wiring diagram of emitter neurons in
terms of their connectivity with
different input and article to reject
this precise wiring diagram will guide
us to study the Prasad function of
distinct neuronal populations within a
particularly input of the circuit and to
ask the question alcohol be precisely
participate in the world learning or
punishment learning so with that I just
want to give a quick summary of our
collaborative project the central goal
is to determine when and where first
neural activity and the neuromodulation
happens during to contraction animal
behaviors in the same form its behaviors
are exemplified by reward learning and
also on war civil onion to achieve this
goal we need to have close collaboration
among the three laps so Haneen John's
lab will develop the capability to
simultaneously image neuromodulatory and
calcium anyways the cellular and
subcellular resolutions chana masala
will establish the input of a pattern of
individual amygdala sub regions and
identify functional subdivision within
the amygdala and the police level or
determine for certain events we then
discrete victor cubes contributed to
behavior and with integration of the
progressed from both genre and
so family we would like to once again
thank the support bro provided by 90s
through this brain initiative grant we
also would like to thank the support
from the wall omen Institute from OHSU
as well as the support from Kozma Harbor
Laboratory I would like to thank you for
your attention